aujourd'hui l'urgence de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont déborde encore un
problème chronique dans plusieurs
hôpitaux du québec
demandé
régulière à des équipes de fonctionner à
150 180 200 % de leurs capacités
la crise perpétuelle aux urgences ne
permet plus d'assurer des soins
sécuritaires
les patients ou les soins aux patients
pour
le dow depuis des années plusieurs
médecins le confier à micro fermé mais
voilà que des médecins écrivent noir sur
blanc que le débordement chronique met
en danger une vie des patients dans une
lettre envoyée au directeur
d'établissement le regroupement des
chefs d'urgence du québec écrit que
plusieurs décès potentiellement
évitables ont été rapportés par les
chefs d'urgence faute d'accès à une
civière et aux soins requis par la
condition très inquiétant les médecins
de des urgentologues qui sont débordés
pour espérer qu'ils attendront tout le
premier mariage entre 2018 et 2022 la
proportion de patients sur civière qui
attendent plus de 24 heures est passé de
17 à 22 % et avec les vacances d'été qui
approchent les hôpitaux réduisent les
services partout sauf aux urgences pour
les prochains semaines mois il faut que
la pression soit répartie ya les chefs
d'urgence exige que les autres
départements absorbe d'une part égale
des débordements je l'avais dit parce
que l'était toujours difficile mais je
pense qu'on est en train de mettre en
place des choses qui vont nous aider si
effectivement il ya eu des morts
évitables c'est quelque chose qui a
vraiment pas fonctionné ça c'est du
ressort de la corona mais les
oppositions est-il que les urgences et
coop pour les autres échecs du réseau
lorsque la cac it arrive au pouvoir y
avait quatre cent mille personnes qui
attendaient un médecin de famille
aujourd'hui à plus d'un million qu'ils
attendent
david qu'on comprend c'est vraiment que
les chefs d'urgence souhaite que les
autres départements partage un peu le
fardeau accepte une partie du phare de
ré les médecins d'urgence disent que
c'est inéquitable parce que pour donner
des vacances aux employés des vacances
méritées ont ralenti par exemple les
chirurgies les consultations mais que
les urgences qui ne peuvent pas fermer
et coop justement de ce ralentissement
des activités donc eu 10 répartition le
le débordement la surcharge
équitablement envoyons des passions
aussi dans les département de chirurgie
et même dans les centres d'hébergement
en surcharge lorsque nous vivons une
surcharge du genre parce que les chefs
d'urgence estime qu'à force de
débordements il y aura des accidents et
qu'il y aurait déjà eu des décès
évitables dans les urgences du québec
mais c'est eux qui le disent donc le
ministre dubé lui pense que des
solutions qui ont déjà été mises en
place mais est ce que ça peut vraiment
améliorer la situation écoutez le
gouvernement a mis sur pied un guichet
d'accès première ligne qui se déploie
graduellement et qui fait en sorte que
théoriquement un patient même orphelin
devrait pouvoir voir assez rapidement un
médecin ou un autre professionnel la
santé mais le problème j'ai l'impression
de me répéter mais ça reste la même
chose c'est que de plus en plus de
médecins qui partent à la retraite est
si difficile de convaincre les
infirmiers infirmières de venir
travailler dans des établissements qui
sont toujours au bord du gouffre donc
oui le gouvernement du québec comme
d'ailleurs dans bien d'autres provinces
fait face à un cercle vicieux qui est
difficile à briser parce que c'est
compliqué d'attirer des employés
lorsqu'on on essaie justement de faire
fonctionner des hôpitaux qui seront au
bord de la crise à l'année longue ou à
peu près en tout cas pour les urgences
ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle et on
n'a pas fini d'en parler merci david en
soirée